-Senate Republicans,
with one notable exception,
completed their cover-up
of the President's crimes today
when they acquitted him
after an impeachment trial
with no witnesses.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Let's just say
it has not been a banner week
for American democracy.
First, of course,
there was the bizarre meltdown
at the Democratic Iowa caucus,
where an app designed
to count people milling around
in high-school gymnasiums
crashed and delayed the results.
The app was built
by a company called Shadow,
which I assume is run
by Christoph waltz
from the Bond films.
[German accent] Shadow!
And the crash resulted in chaos
on the ground
and on cable-news airwaves.
-10:43 Eastern time.
-We still don't have
any results.
-We don't have any results
from Iowa.
-Yeah, Brian, you know,
I've seen or texted with
the Biden campaign manager
a few times tonight.
And what does he keep saying to
me? "We don't know anything."
-Of course, even if the app
worked perfectly,
Joe Biden probably still
wouldn't know anything.
The only app Joe Biden
has ever used is FaceTime
and only by accidentally
sitting on his phone.
"Hello?! Hello?! Honey?!
My wallet's
talking to me again!"
The chaos came after a day
of reporters roaming around
high-school gyms in Iowa
and finding that Biden,
once considered
the front-runner,
was having trouble
gaining traction.
-There was an entire
Biden segment.
Now it looks to be reduced to
just a very small corner here,
so certainly not
a robust turnout.
-The Joe Biden group
probably not going to be viable.
-This is the Joe Biden
section here. Not too much.
-This is the Bernie group.
It's so big that, in fact,
that middle section right there,
with all those folks in it,
that was the Joe Biden section.
And they actually moved
the Joe Biden section
because they didn't have room
for all the Bernie supporters
that are showing up here.
-Biden,
how are we doing over here?
This does not look like
56 people.
So the Biden group --
So, you're -- You look like
lovely, wonderful people,
but it doesn't look like you
made the viability threshold.
-Not yet. There's time, honey.
-There's time. This year?
-Damn!
Jake Tapper is walking around
with a microphone
sassing people
like he's Billy Eichner.
Seriously, Tapper going around
sassing voters
is a show I would watch.
They could call it
"Tap That Sass."
Also, look at this group
of people caucusing for Biden.
They don't exactly look like
they're voting.
They just look like they got
knocked out of
a game of dodgeball.
"I'm so bad at dodging."
"Yeah, me too."
[ Laughter ]
Then yesterday,
the Iowa Democratic Party
finally got around to
announcing partial results,
leaving everyone
somehow even more confused
about what was happening,
resulting in a breathless
Steve Kornacki
racing around the studio
trying to digest
all of the number vomit
that was being dumped on him.
-Got a lot of questions here.
I got to dive into these
and see where these came from.
Not every county gets, you know,
state delegate equivalents
that are equal to the turnout.
Sanders -- 30%.
Iowa City, Johnson County.
Sanders -- 33%.
Getting big numbers
in these places.
I'm out of breath here. Sorry.
-My God. Someone
get that man some oxygen.
Also, there are 49 states to go,
Kornacki!
You got to pace yourself!
You're going to need the paddles
by Super Tuesday.
In case you thought
this couldn't get
any more complicated,
it turns out the Iowa caucus
used some complicated math
similar to
the electoral-college system
in order to give more weight
to rural areas,
meaning you could
actually win more delegates
even while losing
the popular vote.
-Buttigieg's campaign right now
is in the lead in this category,
state delegate equivalents.
We've been saying
this is a bit like
the electoral-college/
popular-vote thing
where there's the potential
for a split.
And right now, with 62% of
the expected vote in in Iowa,
that's what you're seeing.
So, again,
the possibility here --
Very possible right now that
Buttigieg is going to hang on,
win the state-delegate
equivalents.
That's the traditional way
these things have been decided.
And that Sanders is going to
get to say, "Hey, look.
More people came out
to support me than Buttigieg."
The thing that's taking him from
close to the lead, actually,
is that peculiar state-delegate
equivalent allocation formula.
When you apply that,
Buttigieg takes the lead.
-Just give it to the person
who gets the most votes!
Why?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Please answer me.
Why did "American Idol"
have a better system
than actual America?
And yet, while Bernie,
who was actually leading
the popular vote,
remained restrained,
Buttigieg flew to New Hampshire
with more confidence.
-I don't know
how anybody declares victory
before you have
an official statement
as to the election results.
So we're not declaring victory.
-They're not complete,
but results are in
from a majority of precincts,
and they show our campaign
in first place.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey, man, you can't just
declare yourself in first place
when all the results aren't in
and you're not even winning
the popular vote.
That's not how it works.
If that were the case,
then I could just declare myself
"People's" Sexiest Man Alive
right now.
And do you know --
do you know how pissed
Adam Driver would be?
Probably not at all
because we're basically twins.
Also, I love the contrast
between how polished Pete is
and the fact that Bernie
is doing his press conference
on an airplane,
apparently in coach.
"These seats are too roomy!
Who needs this much space?!
I'm going to sit
in that over there overhead!"
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
"Pass me some pretzels!"
So, that was the state
of democracy on Monday.
Then, last night,
an impeached president,
who lost the popular vote, gave
the State of the Union address
in which he demonized immigrants
and lied repeatedly
from job numbers to immigration
to tax cuts to drug prices.
For example, at one point,
Trump called on Congress
to pass a bill to lower
prescription-drug prices,
a bill Democrats have already
passed in the House
and which Mitch McConnell
has refused to take up
in the Senate.
The bill is called HR3,
and some Democrats started
chanting the bill's name
in response to Trump's lie.
-I'm calling
for bipartisan legislation
that achieves the goal
of dramatically lowering
prescription drug prices.
Get a bill on my desk,
and I will sign it into law
immediately.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-HR 3! HR 3!
-With unyielding commitment...
-I love that
they're chanting the bill's name
because you know Trump
has no idea what that means.
[ Laughter ]
"HR?
Wait. What?
Isn't that where women file
all their complaints about me?
I thought there
were way more than three."
[ Laughter ]
As is always the case with
Trump, there were so many lies,
it was impossible to keep track,
and the constant stream of lies
from Trump prompted glares
of disapproval from Democrats,
bewilderment from
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi,
and a solemn head shake
from Congressman Jim Clyburn.
That face really sums it up
right there.
That's the face you make
when your daughter tells you
she's engaged
to a philosophy major.
[ Laughter ]
"How are you gonna eat?"
Compare that to the reactions
of Republicans in the crowd,
like smirking
'80s movie villains
Neil Gorsuch
and Brett Kavanaugh.
And a horrifying smile from
Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell,
who looked like Chucky
pretending he's not possessed.
"Well, I'm just a --
I'm just a regular old doll.
You can go to bed now.
I'm not, uh...
I'm not gonna do evil
once you sleep."
[ Laughter ]
Go to bed.
Just a regular doll."
[ Laughter ]
Those two moments
are perfect illustrations
of the crisis to democracy
we're currently facing.
A majority leader,
who actually represents
a minority of Americans,
working with a president
who lost the popular vote
by 3 million,
installed two
Supreme Court justices
with lifetime appointments.
Now, every President uses
the State of the Union address
to do a little campaigning,
but Trump turned it
into a full-on rally.
At one point, Republicans
literally started chanting
"Four more years."
-Four more years!
Four more years!
-Cool. The State of the Union
just turned into a Trump rally.
I mean, the only difference
is Trump is squinting his way
through a speech
someone else wrote for him
instead of riffing
about insane stuff like this.
-Sinks, toilets, and showers.
You don't get any water.
-Four less flushes!
Four less flushes!
And the undying devotion
most Republicans have pledged
to a shameless, corrupt liar
was on full display today
when they acquitted him
after a sham impeachment trial,
in which
they ignored the evidence
and refused
to hear from witnesses.
A senate Republican caucus,
again representing
a minority of Americans,
acquitted a president
who lost the popular vote
in the 2016 election
and tried to cheat
in the 2020 election.
You can't call that democracy.
I mean, you could,
but then Jim Clyburn
would give you this look again.
[ Laughter ]
The only Republican who shocked
Washington today
by announcing he would vote
to convict Trump
and remove him from office,
was Utah Senator Mitt Romney.
Romney announced his decision
in both a floor speech
and on Fox News.
-Were I to ignore the evidence
that has been presented
and disregard what I believe
my oath and the Constitution
demands of me,
for the sake of a partisan end,
it would, I fear,
expose my character
to history's rebuke
and the censure
of my own conscience.
Applying impartial justice said
what the President did
was grievously wrong,
and I had to vote,
if I was gonna live
with my own conscience,
in a way that was consistent
with that oath of office.
-First of all,
I love he did it on Fox News
just to enrage Trump even more.
Trump's aides probably had
to put duct tape over the TV
to make the headline say, "Trump
is a good boy, and I love him."
[ Laughter ]
Second, it's shocking
just to hear a Republican
talk about
living with their conscience.
Most Republicans
filed for divorce
from their consciences
years ago.
That's why Mitch McConnell
is always smiling like that.
[ Laughter ]
"I do have a conscience.
I'm not a haunted doll."
[ Laughter ]
"Go to bed."
But while Romney was standing
alone among Republicans,
the rest of his colleagues,
who voted to acquit Trump,
were busy making excuses and
actually trying to convince us
that Trump
won't just try to cheat again.
Here's Maine Senator
Susan Collins
explaining her vote yesterday.
-Are you confident
that the President
won't seek
foreign assistance again?
-I believe that the President
has learned from this case.
-What do you believe
the President has learned?
-The President
has been impeached.
That's a pretty big lesson.
-Are you insane?
Donald Trump
doesn't learn lessons.
He's like an untrained dog.
If he pees on the floor,
you got to rub his nose in it.
And even then,
he'll probably do it again
while making
direct eye contact with you.
[ Laughter ]
Collins' argument falls on
the heels of Tennessee Senator
Lamar Alexander, who made
a similar argument on Sunday.
-Are you at all concerned,
though,
when you seek
foreign interference --
He does not believe
he's done anything wrong.
That what has happened here
might encourage him
that he can continue to do this?
-I don't think so.
I hope not.
I mean, enduring an impeachment
is something
that nobody should like.
Even the President said he
didn't want that on his résumé.
I don't blame him.
So, if a call like that
gets you an impeachment,
I would think you would think
twice before he did it again.
-What did his -- What --
What example
in the life of Donald Trump,
has he been chastened?
-[ Chuckles ]
I haven't studied his life
that close.
-Yeah, you don't have to
study his life
because he's been in tabloids
and on reality TV
for like 40 years.
Everyone knows every intimate
detail of his personal life.
If Donald Trump could strap
a GoPro to his head
and livestream every moment of
his life, he'd probably do it.
Except it would suck because
all we'd see is Fox News,
fast food, golf balls
slicing out of bounds,
and women from the neck down.
[ Laughter ]
"HR 4."
This week
has showcased in vivid terms
the crisis of democracy
we're facing.
With the exception
of Mitt Romney,
a Republican caucus representing
a minority of Americans
acquitted a corrupt
Republican President
who lost the popular vote
and lied repeatedly in his
State of the Union address.
Republicans are devoted to Trump
above all else,
and they're willing to flush
both our democracy
and our Constitution
down multiple...
-Toilets!
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]